foreign
[Music]
because they're clicking this [ __ ] and
they might be they might be clicking
this [ __ ] two years from now
they might have clicked this [ __ ] two
years ago
sure it's all yeah time is a flat circle
it's a flat Mobius strip it's kind of
like
it's part of the space time continuum
yeah yeah the space time all the times
are one time exactly it's just a
singularity
said scene Cobra Kai we wait do you mean
did you seen it or are you asking us if
we've seen he's Mexican he's gonna
[ __ ] just say whatever he wants to
say coming out of his mouth [ __ ] Khan
go ahead and [ __ ] let's conjugate
some [ __ ] let's let's do [ __ ] past
present and future kind of situation
going on this is English well I'm just
saying no that's that is English but I
don't know if it's declarative or if
it's a question he's thinking in he's
thinking in a romance language okay he
hasn't he hasn't entered the Articles or
the tents okay okay into the verb
conjugation yeah there you go he's
asking us did we see Cobra Kai yes we
saw this episode but we haven't had time
to like watch the rest of it yet yeah
and we probably won't have time tonight
either because we have enough because
com was telling me says man you got to
see the new Cobra Kai it's [ __ ]
awesome and it was that very first
episode it was good I had to remember
who it was I'd forgotten some of those
characters from the last season because
it had been so long
but you're right you're right but you
you're right man the uh
the production quality moved up a little
bit but we got to wait we only saw the
very first episode yeah but I got I got
a feeling it's going to be a good season
constant was the best season of all
season I probably feel like
Thursday night we'll probably watch
right yeah the rest of it well I don't
know how many episodes there are in the
season I didn't look because we just saw
the first one like tonight we have to
watch a movie tomorrow night we're gonna
do the main show so we'll probably be
like too tired and or drunk or we were
we were tired and we had been drinking
when we saw the first episode of the new
season of cover guy it was good though
yeah I remember it yeah I remember it
too I remember we hadn't we didn't drink
that it's happening in Mexico yeah and I
was like okay this just happened at Max
of course Khan's gonna like this [ __ ]
but no the the story seems to be strong
the way they're setting it up it's 10
episodes he says okay so we're probably
not gonna be able to watch the whole
thing no but Thursday night we'll try to
make a dent in it because that's the
first night where we don't have like
other [ __ ] going it's hilarious man it's
hilarious as nostalgic as [ __ ] the
Cobra as as the [ __ ] Karate Kid
Trilogy was
and let's face it Karate Kid 3 was not
that great it was okay you know but
it's funny that they made such a good
retro series out of that they're
bringing back karate
bringing karate back all right what kind
of [ __ ] is that but they did they
brought they did they brought Karai back
yeah okay see anything can be done
if you know what you're doing yeah it's
the karate version of [ __ ] stranger
things basically yeah you still need to
watch that but I haven't seen it but you
still need to watch it yeah yeah you
haven't seen any of it I haven't even
like I haven't finished the newest
season yet either that's another thing I
see nothing but just what's he saying I
can't read on my glasses
um yeah it said there's 10 episodes it
says the last one is badass fingers
flying with sword fights okay see there
you go all right yeah I got back from
the biker bar I was drinking up at the
biker bar for about an hour or so no you
don't say like I'm pretty sure everybody
can like it was [ __ ] hilarious what I
was doing this is all kinds of [ __ ]
[ __ ] with the dudes that run the damn
lawn cruise at the [ __ ]
golf courses around here and just you
know just doing what I do they had a guy
[ __ ] showed up with like a 2 000
[ __ ]
2010 [ __ ] Dodge Viper or something it
was pretty [ __ ] sweet you know just
looking at cars and stuff
talking about motorcycles that's all
slasher friend said this movie is kind
of like alien but in a cave yeah kinda I
kind of feel like it's more like the
thing more like the thing and honestly
like Neil Marshall the guy that wrote
and directed it um he said that was one
of his big influences really was the
thing yeah he did it right yeah well
yeah so the weirdest I called it I was
watching I was because man this is like
the thing yeah he's a big fan of he
liked um he said he also was used like
Italian horror like Dario Argento and
stuff but mainly he's like the thing was
like yeah well as soon as I saw that it
was all female cast I was like this is
kind of like the thing well that he they
didn't really initially they weren't
going to do that
um they said originally it was going to
be like a mixed group like men and women
but then when they were kind of talking
they said you know it's really really
rare to see a horror movie that has an
all-female cast and I was like yeah that
is actually kind of weird well the thing
about it is it's weird because I kind of
feel like if the all the cast was men I
don't really think most people would
comment on it yeah um but when it's
women like everybody has like when it's
all women everybody's like flip it out
which is like really really weird or
like commenting on it I kind of feel
like if it was all men they wouldn't
comment on it it's better as all women
yeah I mean it is I yeah I thought it
was as well that way it's like there's a
bunch of Dynamics going on between women
that
that it's kind of the Dynamics in a
certain way that you see in the thing
yeah okay and uh no I [ __ ] love it
you know I mean it's gendered Horror in
a certain way it's
um
it's a bunch of women and
one of the women's kind of dishonorable
you know yeah it sucks spoiler alert
she's asking not very honorable got a
lot of people in trouble
she got hers in the end though and I
like the fact that it was all women
yeah I like that too like I said even
though that wasn't the original idea
like when he came up with the script but
when he was talking with like the with
the producers and stuff it's like hey
why don't we make it all women and he's
like yeah that's a good idea and he's
like and I really wanted it I mean he
specifically wanted he's like I don't
really want them to be like sexualized
and the fact that we were putting them
like these sexy outfits or anything like
that he's like I wanted all their
clothes to be like kind of practical and
he's like and I just wanted them
to be you know because he's a man and
he's just like well I wanted them to be
as realistic as possible so he ran
everything like by his female friends
and everything that's like hey would a
woman say that or would a woman do that
so he seemed like he was really trying
to get it correct and he did to be
honest in the movie like the Dynamics
between the characters I don't see it as
really that different uh than the
Dynamics between like for example like
you know the the men and the thing
because I I kind of feel like that's
analogous because you know the thing is
all men
um you know they have their own kind of
little things going on too like in their
own but I don't like I said I don't
really think it's all that different
like the way they relate to one another
it's really not it's not but but you
have to understand that in the thing one
it's a military slash Mission oriented
situation right yeah so that's different
but it actually no not that much because
they're in this damn cave [ __ ]
exploration situation which is also kind
of like a mission oriented thing yeah
and there's a lot of ego and stuff going
on between [ __ ] got people that are
explorers for caves and it happens to be
women so no it's understandable it's
realistic yeah they're all like Thrill
Seekers yeah but I and I like too that
most of them are like really really have
done this lots of times before but then
there's one that's only done it a few
times so I like that so they had to have
one character that kind of like hadn't
done it as much as the others so you
could kind of explain things for the
audience like to that one I'm gonna I'm
gonna disagree all right that they were
unsexual no I thought they were sexy
well yeah but I'm just saying that he
wasn't on purpose like trying to it's
just the way it is right okay
um they were they were wearing cool
outfits that were like Mission oriented
and it was all women that were competent
in what they were doing and I just
thought that was sexy yeah all right so
you can't unsexualize women
I think he not from a man I think he
missed that I think he meant that he's
like I didn't want it to be like you
know women that are cheesy cheesy right
like women that are going into caves
like oh I'm having like a bra and
panties and he's like if we had this
other producer on the film that was like
oh well there has to be a scene where
they all take their clothes off and like
jump and he's like yeah we're not doing
that it's like you know what I mean
we're keeping everything very practical
like it would be in real life yeah so I
kind of appreciated that that's what he
meant when he said that he didn't yeah
because if you ask me competent women
are sexy I just think they are sure so
that you know you're not going to be
able to unsexify it it's just it'd be
stupid to do so you know I just think a
common competent women are sexy and
they're in their doing this [ __ ] cave
exploration thing and they have their
own pecking order
which as a guy I'm gonna say that's sexy
well and the thing that's cool about
this movie too is that there's a lot of
characters and you know there's dialogue
between them and everything but I kind
of feel like a lot of the dynamic
between all the group is
kind of conveyed to the audience without
a lot of dialogue like a lot of it has
to do with like the way it's shot the
way they look at one another yeah like
sometimes some of the situations that
come up like there's not a lot of
exposition but you can kind of tell the
way they react one like a lot of things
are implied yeah um the way they react
to one another the way they react in
certain situations which is good I mean
that's kind of like I think that's the
reason that this movie uh usually comes
up on like best horror movies of the
21st century because it's very very show
don't tell yeah you know they had that
one girl who was joking that she was
sport [ __ ] that other girl you don't
know if that was actually happening or
not it was still sexy that she said that
yeah
I don't know if she really was sport
[ __ ] that girl but then she goes I'm
a sport [ __ ] that girl and then later
on I have a bunch of kids anyway a bunch
of babies so I don't I don't know if she
was just [ __ ] I don't know if she
meant that exactly
um what that because one of the themes
of this movie like if you want to go to
it is kind of like um you know know the
main character whose family all dies in
that horrible car accident at the
beginning she's kind of like the one
that's you know kind of I don't want to
say like grown up but she uh you know
had a husband and a kid and she was
maybe getting away from doing uh you
know all of these kind of like um crazy
you know uh like cave Expeditions that
they had been doing before so I think
some of the theme too is that people
that are like aging out of that kind of
thing and versus people that are still
like young enough and still want to like
retain their youth and want to do like
all this crazy [ __ ] so there was a
little bit of a conflict there so I
think that's kind of more what she meant
like she's just going around sport
[ __ ] I don't know if she necessarily
but she was sport [ __ ] that girl but
she was just sport [ __ ] people in
general I thought she said and then
she's like then later on she can settle
down and have babies and all that other
kind of stuff but now she's just kind of
like sleeping around I thought that
that's what she meant because I thought
she said I'm sport [ __ ] Network well
she might have been I'm just saying that
I think that the implication was she was
just like sleeping around just having a
good time but then later on she would
settle down
did you know though
see I don't think she said exactly she
didn't say that I don't think she said
for a [ __ ] Juno you just that was
just in your fantasy
I thought she said I'm supporting
[ __ ] Juno but then later on I'm gonna
have all these kind of babies that's I
thought she said yeah I don't know if
she said I don't remember she said her
name
um Forester down said a group of men
needed shape-shifting alien to generate
mistrust in a group of women It comes
naturally I don't know if I don't know
if that's natural I don't think that's
the case yeah you're being you're being
that way but yeah well and honestly
um I kind of feel like if it was a group
of men there's if there's one dude that
was like that [ __ ] other people over
like Juno did in this one you know I've
been different dudes would have been
that's what I'm in dudes would have been
the same way and honestly in my
experience and I know this is anecdotal
but in my experience like groups of
dudes are like are way bigger [ __ ]
than women are fish like in my
experience especially a bunch of Alphas
yeah a bunch of Alphas are oh they're so
so [ __ ] so [ __ ] [ __ ] way more
than like groups of women that I knew I
mean no no but a group of alpha dudes in
the military type situation I've been
there [ __ ] lived it since you they're
they're a mean girl on steroids yeah
that's what I mean girl on steroids
that's what I mean and all those Elite
military outfits [ __ ] you know what I
mean like Recon which I came for
recomplishing [ __ ] Ranger units and
[ __ ] like that [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
Mean Girls yeah yeah yep it might as
well be a goddamn beauty pageant it's
always who's fun yeah they're always
like training undermining one another
stronger than you I'm tougher than you
yeah it's always like that like I said I
don't even think that's a gendered thing
that's just a huge thing that's ego ego
yeah that's exactly what it is yeah so
and that's and I think that doesn't even
depend on the gender I think that just
depends on the person some people are
kind of like more egotistical than
others and yeah you know whether they're
men or women men have strong EOS when
they're young and they will [ __ ] you if
you're in around a bunch of them and
that's part of the test in all those
Elite military units is can you deal
with these [ __ ] [ __ ] and
negotiate that [ __ ] and then how long
and and it never lasts forever it's only
a few years you're constantly replaced
because they got to stock the [ __ ]
shelves they gotta [ __ ] rotate stock
you're too old now now you go
it's always the same
slasher Fred also says and we're gonna
get into this in a little bit too uh
there are two versions of the movie the
US version of the UK version yeah
um I'm gonna say like the version we
watched we actually watched the version
that was on Amazon Prime here's the
weird thing I thought that we had
already reviewed this movie and we very
well may have but I told Tom I was like
well go look and see
um because I was like I could have sworn
that we already did I know we did dog
soldiers which is Neil's Neil Marshall's
uh first film which came out in 2002
which is also excellent and this was
like his second one and I was like I
could have sworn it's like I know like
because you had it and I was like I know
we've watched it fairly recently so I
was like and then like the weird thing
too is that when I went on YouTube today
and I was like watching other people's
reviews of it I had watched all of them
before so I was like that usually would
entail that we had reviewed it before
because then I would watch all this
video I bought this [ __ ] on Blu-ray but
maybe we thought about doing it and then
didn't I bought this [ __ ] on Blu-ray
and it only plays on some of my players
doesn't play on my Xbox yeah
I don't know but we watched it on Amazon
Prime yeah because we weren't even like
thinking about it I was just kind of
like went on Amazon Prime and I was like
oh it's you know it's October now so all
of the streaming services are putting up
all the classic horror movies and I was
like woohoo so we're going through and
Tom's like oh let's watch The Descent
he's like because I've been wanting to
see that again he'd seen it before but
he wasn't really paying attention
um and he had the DVD but like he said
you can't play it like on some of the
players so maybe that's why we didn't
end up reviewing it before if we didn't
so we ended up just watching because I
was like hey that's fine with me because
I really like that movie now I've seen
it several times the first time I saw it
was on an airplane when I was going
when I was either go I think I was going
to the UK so I was flying from like
Orlando to London and
The Descent is not the ideal film to
watch on an airplane like especially for
somebody like me that really does not
like to fly and I get like super
stressed out about it because the
descent is like a really
stressful movie to watch and it's like I
didn't need you know because I can't
sleep on a plane and it was like an
overnight flight and so I'm watching it
to like entertain myself and I'm like
halfway through I'm like man this was a
mistake because I was like already
stressed out from the flight and then
I'm like then I had this piling the
stress from this movie like on top of it
and I was like yeah so uh it wasn't a
good experience but yeah that's uh the
first time I saw it but I think the cool
thing about this movie too is that I
don't know like I said it's really
really good like show don't tell kind of
stuff and even if it didn't have the
monsters in it I don't I hesitate to
call them monsters because they're kind
of like they're humanoid yeah and they
imply that they evolved down there
um you know what I mean because they're
like cave people but they're kind of
like animals but sort of human
I kind of feel like this even if it
didn't have those I'm glad that it has
those because that's because they're
cool but I kind of feel like even if it
didn't have that I think this would
still be a terrifying movie you know you
know it's you know what's weird too is
that they were working on this movie
and it so happened that there was like a
bigger budget like American movie that
was gonna come out like at the same time
that was called The Cave that has a very
very similar premise and it was just
like a total coincidence they were just
kind of like we didn't even know that
somebody else was working on a cave
movie and I haven't seen the movie
called The Cave I've heard it's okay but
it's interesting that that so The
Descent they had to put it into the rule
like we want ours to come out first so
they basically shot it Neil Marshall
said we shot it in January and February
they shot the whole thing in the UK all
the cave stuff that's all um that's all
Pinewood Studios they built all those
sets because they said it'd be too
dangerous to like shoot in a real cave
obviously
um so they said we shot it in January
and February and it was in theaters in
the UK by July so they're like that was
a very very quick turnaround time
because they were trying to get it out
before the caves it didn't look like
they were like ripping it off but the
weird thing is that I kind of feel like
nobody talks about the movie The Cave
but everybody still talks about this one
this came out in 2005 so I guess that
was like the right decision like I said
I haven't seen the cave maybe it's good
um they did make a sequel to this movie
as well which
Danny Rowling said he liked it as much
but I did not like it and most people I
kind of feel like most people don't like
it but I'm not saying that it's like
that's the wrong opinion to have or
anything like that that you like it but
I really didn't like it and the thing
about it too is that the sequel I mean
Neil Marshall they said they asked him
about it and they said hey we're gonna
make a sequel and he's like yeah I don't
think you should do that and um they're
like well we're gonna do it anyway
though because you don't have the rights
yeah yeah
well how would you make a sequel to that
that's what he said yeah well and
because I was reading an interview with
him just now and um they said well how
did they make a sequel without you he
said well the you know one of the ways
they got the movie made was um pathe
that studio they owned the rights and
because the movie was so successful I
think cost less than four million pounds
to make and then it made like 60 70
million dollars and um so they're like
yeah we're making a sequel to this and
he's like um they were like what do you
think and he's like I think you
shouldn't do it and because it's dumb uh
because you know it's a it's a contained
story and specifically like when we get
into the whole thing about like the
different endings and everything like
definitely the UK or the global ending
you know uh
there's another sequel because they're
all dead but um but yeah
so he's like well don't do it they said
we're gonna do it anyway and then he's
like I try to give him some advice about
it he's like well don't [ __ ] it up and
then he's like they weren't really
listening to me so I was just like
[ __ ] I just like wash my hands of it
you know what I mean so um you know I
remember it wasn't terrible but I don't
really remember anything all that much
about it and I was watching Ryan
Hollinger like earlier and he's just
like yeah the sequel is [ __ ] like don't
bother with it so I don't know and like
I said the sequel
the sequel like uh goes off of the US
ending which is actually like cut off I
don't know how many people know this
that watched it in the United States if
you watch The Descent in the United
States
the movie ends with
um Sarah Escaping The Cave like she gets
out she runs to the truck or whatever
and like she's screaming and freaking
out like holy [ __ ] let's just like Sally
at the end of Texas Chainsaw Massacre
which that's what he was homaging uh he
said that and then she kind of like
turns and sees Juno who's a ghost
because everybody else was dead in the
cave and that's where the US movie ends
now the movie in the UK and everywhere
else in the world except for the United
States doesn't end there it actually ha
it does that scene and then it jumps to
the end scene which shows that Sarah
never escaped from the cave at all she's
still in the cave and that was a
hallucination that she had
so she dies in the cave too presumably
they don't show her dying
but they kind of show her going off into
her own like she's kind of sitting there
she's all covered with blood and then
she's looking at the torch but she's
seeing the torch as like her daughters
her dead daughter's birthday cake and
she's kind of like smiling so like she's
kind of like seeing she's gonna die but
she sees that's she's so got far gone
that that's what she sees so it's almost
like like Neil Marshall was like I kind
of thought that was the happier ending
because like if she escaped she's
clearly like not right she's all like
screaming and freaking out and it's like
and she might get in trouble for all of
the people being dead in the cave like
with all the cops and everything so he's
like so I don't see that as a happy
ending but he's like in a way even
though everybody died like in the UK
version he's like I kind of see that as
happier because at least she thinks that
she's going to be with her daughter you
know what I mean because she doesn't
really have anything left to live for
anymore so he's like I kind of feel like
that was a happy writing but you know so
the fact that they made a sequel that
whole thing is predicated upon it having
the U.S ending where she escaped now I
don't remember is the same actress in
the
in the sequel does anybody remember
Danny Rowling said the sequel's ending
was [ __ ] yeah
I mean that's the thing but um but yeah
so
what else I was gonna say something like
uh something else about this as well
and now I can't remember what it was but
yeah so so the endings are different I
don't know and they kind of asked him
too they're like well
I guess it was a test audience thing
like they showed the movie to test
audiences in the US and they said oh
that ending was like such a bummer so
they chopped off like the last few
minutes of it
but I don't know he's like I thought it
was dumb that he's like I think it's a
cliche that Americans always have to
have Happy Endings he's like I don't
think that's true
um he's like look at because he even
made the example he's like look at
something like seven which has like a
super super Bleak ending and that was
like massively successful so he's like I
don't really think that that's a thing
that Americans have to have Happy
Endings but I do kind of feel like that
that's a cliche
that particularly a lot of Europeans
because they'll do that like with a lot
of European movies not just horror
movies either like if it has an ending
that's kind of a bummer like where
everybody dies or something like that
and they show it to American Test
audiences they'll be like yeah we don't
like that and you have to change it and
like make the ending happier so I kind
of feel like yeah or at least like more
uplifting Americans want a [ __ ]
optimistic ending in the end like oh
yeah our characters made it it's just
the way they are
I think a lot of I think a lot of
audiences are like that though maybe
it's just I don't know South American
audiences are like that yeah yeah they
want optimism
because they've put themselves in the
[ __ ] shoes of these characters so
they want hope that they can survive
because they saw the characters survive
you know what I'm talking about yeah
they don't like any of that Bleak [ __ ] I
don't well okay their lives are too hard
you know yeah they get that they don't
want to go through that [ __ ] again
I'm gonna be diplomatic about it because
I'm gonna say it depends on the movie
um I kind of feel like sometimes a bleak
ending goes along with the whole theme
of the story of the story that you're
trying to tell sometimes a happy ending
goes along with the story that you're
trying to tell I kind of feel like in
this particular Story the theme of it
the way that it was laid out I kind of
feel like the UK ending was the better
ending
um for the for the exact reason that
Neil Marshall said he's like I don't
think her escaping and being crazy and
her whole family and all her friends
being dead is a happy ending I can
remember being young
in Brazil
watching Predator one
in a theater full of Brazilians and they
love that movie they loved it
and I could feel it from them and I felt
into myself that I just watched a great
piece of Cinema and I was right it
[ __ ] stood the test of time over the
decades
in the Brazilian audience liked the fact
that Arnold survived a bunch of people
died but Arnold survived and that the
girl survived they liked that
yeah they like the part where the
American dudes cut the girl loose
I said okay you're on our side they love
that you know yeah I can see that and uh
because you know what I mean there was
a lot of question in Central and South
America are Americans good guys or bad
guys but when they when Arnold cut that
girl loose it's okay you're with us you
gotta survive you know what I mean then
they went okay well Americans are good
people that's the way they saw that yeah
so
and I was there with it you know I
watched this [ __ ] happened in a mixed
audience well a mixed audience I was the
mix
they were all Brazilians yeah I mean so
I watched it with them they loved that
movie
and I talked to my Brazilian friends to
this day they still love Predator one
Terminator one all that kind of [ __ ] so
it's a legendary even with them
you know just that's all I'm gonna say
but I'm gonna say that I think kind of
optimism right but like I said I don't
think that's true across the board
though like it depends on what kind of
movie that's what I'm saying like for
predator I think that was a good that
was the right choice right like the
ending that that had this movie I think
the Bleak ending is better right just
because there's a ripping you didn't
Escape yeah yeah well and like I said in
some ways because she's just kind of
like gone completely [ __ ] doolally as
uh Gordon Ramsay would say and as I said
all her friends are dead her family is
dead they got killed like a year
previously she doesn't really have I
mean the fact that she just like went
she just like shut down and was like yep
[ __ ] that I'm going off into la la land
where my daughter's still alive and yeah
she's gonna get eaten by the by the
creatures but she's not seeing it like
that so to me that almost seems like a
happier ending than her like escaping so
um
Danny or no Ben said the sequel was all
about whether she was crazy and killed
all her friends yeah see that's kind of
like why I think that her escaping
ultimately wouldn't be a happy ending
because you don't really know like if
somebody popped out a cave and they had
gone down there with like a half dozen
of their friends or whatever and then
they all turned up dead and she came out
and said look for real there were like
Monsters down there and they ate all of
them like you know it would believe her
everybody thought everybody would think
that she was just like a nutcase it and
the thing about it is like they could
probably I mean even if they found the
bodies they could probably prove that
she now she didn't kill Juno but she
left her there to die like I you know
and I hate to say but Juno was like a
dick so she probably had that coming you
know what I mean like well because not
only was Juno it's very strongly implied
[ __ ] around with Sarah's husband like
before Sarah's husband got killed so
that's very strongly implied but she's
the one that got them all in that mess
in the first place because she told them
that they were going to this one cave
system and then she didn't even take the
book and then took him down this
completely unexplored cave system and
she didn't know [ __ ] all about like
where it was going or if they could even
get out and like didn't tell them until
they were already all the way down there
so it was all like her fault just
because she was an [ __ ] like with a
massive ego it's like oh well I thought
we could just like name it because
nobody had been down here we could
Discover it and I'm just like [ __ ] you
are yeah so can you read I haven't
[ __ ] I don't have my glasses on I
can't read what's going on
let's see uh holy parachute Doom said
some stories require the downer ending
yeah I agree uh like this one but I'm so
tired of movies where the killers win
it's more fun if victims turn the tables
uh on their predators yeah and you know
like I said I kind of feel like it
depends on the story it depends on the
story sometimes I like oblique ending
but it is kind of fun like to see the
victims like fight back and like get
some measure of uh even if they lose
ultimately like at least you like to see
them like fight back against the
monsters I guess like especially like in
horror movies
it's weird because when now that you
bring up the thing about the sequel to
this about
um her being crazy and killing all her
friends uh that's a theory that's been
circling around the original movie I
don't know if I
buy that reading because Neil Marshall
said that when he was originally came up
with the script he's like we wanted to
leave it ambiguous as to whether the
they called them the Crawlers like the
the cave monsters were real or if they
were just like a figment of Sarah's
imagination and like then ultimately we
kind of went with yeah they're real but
there's still like enough ambiguity in
the movie that some people have theories
that actually Sarah because throughout
the movie like Sarah is having at least
auditory hallucinations like she keeps
hearing her dead daughter like giggling
like in the cave and stuff and they left
that in so some people have have
hypothesized that that all of it is in
Her Imagination like she's like just
totally lost her mind and she goes down
in the cave and then she kills all the
all her friends and then like but she
sees it as monsters but the thing about
it is that if you watch the movie
nowadays like with that I don't really
know if you can sustain that theory
because all of the other women see them
too you know what I'm saying so I don't
think she's just like making it up but
he wanted like when in the first early
stages he said we were kind of playing
with the idea of there weren't any
monsters that she was just like seeing
it like that but it was really her like
killing them the whole time but I don't
know I don't know if the way the movie
is like supports that reading anymore
but he said that was one thing that they
were kind of throwing around at the
beginning
so there's that
um somebody said that they really really
liked the um the makeup on the monsters
yeah I really liked him too and they
said that when they first did the
monster design that they actually made
them more monstery but then like as time
went on they kind of made them more
humanoid because I think the idea
developed later that these would
actually they started out as humans
and then they'd live down in this cave
so long that they'd essentially like
evolved into this like where they're you
know all white and they're blind and you
know they click like bats like for
echolocation and everything like that
which I thought was like a really cool
idea
um I do we think I I don't know like
if
if it's kind of like these were the the
people that lived in the cave initially
the ones that did the cave paintings and
then over thousands of years like they
evolved into what they were
or have these creatures like been there
a longer time because I kind of feel
like if I'm not mistaken I feel like
some of the bones that were piled up
like from all the stuff they'd eaten I
thought some of those looked like like
neanderthals and stuff like that
you know what I mean I think they were I
think they were Crow Manion yeah maybe
did Crow Manion because it was Crow
Manion paintings that they that they
were showing
and then they uh they just evolved into
something else they were just you know
they were they were a Subterranean Crow
Manion there were carnivores
eating deer and Elk
that's all it was
yeah because they found like that uh
that elk or whatever like up at the top
like the Elkin caribou
and deer
and uh they were carnivores
use an echo echolocation like a bat yeah
like everything was like it was just
like human bats
which
I'm not plausible I liked that idea yeah
because it's kind of plausible because
like I said if animals like whatever
animals there if they evolve in caves
for like a long enough time they usually
will lose all their coloration they
usually lose their sight because you
don't need it and other things like that
so I don't think it's crazy to think
they were going along the lines of a
[ __ ] book that I read when I was
younger called Eaters of the Dead
and I believed it I thought it was a
[ __ ] book a real book but turns out
but it wasn't real and from from that
book Jenny's because I told Jenny about
the book because I read this book called
Eaters of the dead and I know that there
are [ __ ]
weird-ass chromanians and in [ __ ]
neanderthals has survived earlier on and
I was telling her about it she's like
wait what and then and
turns out it was a fig it was a book of
fiction yeah but it was written as as uh
and from that book it was found footage
it's found
from that book they made they made the
movie [ __ ]
um 13th Warrior
yeah came from that book but I thought
that that book was real that it was
really something from the Viking era but
no it wasn't
and that's what they did in this one
okay
um the the vendor okay in the 13th
Warrior or in Eaters of the Dead they
were fighting these creatures called the
vendel
and the Vandal were
described in a certain way that would
make you think that they were
Neanderthal
or something like that
but they were but the whole book was a
fraud okay it was meant to be kind of
like found footage
and yeah see people think found footage
is a new phenomenon it's totally not
they were doing that back in the old
days man yeah they were doing that [ __ ]
yeah they were doing the back of the
Victorian I believed it I believed it
and my dad believed it my dad was the
one that gave me the book you gotta read
this book yeah but your dad also
believed them
yeah about that before I like gotta read
this that Discovery though and I read it
and I was like oh hell yeah see I told
you you know that kind of [ __ ] and then
when the book wasn't that old
yeah Danny Rowling brings up that movie
The Cave now I haven't seen it and I
kind of feel like nobody talks about it
because it came out like you know about
the same time as this and has a very
similar premise like I said even though
it was completely coincidental that that
happened but I mean if anybody's seen it
is it any good like is it worth watching
I kind of saw some clips of it I'm like
yeah that does look kind of similar but
I'm sure it had like some other stuff
it's funny because when we were watching
The Descent last night and you were kind
of getting into it and I said oh you
know what other horror movie you might
like which is not it's similar but not
exactly it's kind of like a survival
horror kind of thing is the ruins you
would probably like that yeah like I
read the novel too like the novel is
Amazing by Scott Smith the same guy that
wrote A Simple Plan
and uh but they made like a decent movie
adaptation of it and it's kind of like
I don't want to give too much but it's
kind of like a survival horror thing and
it takes place in Mexico like in an
archaeological dig that's all I'm gonna
say but yeah you probably like it I feel
like a lot of people have seen it when
did it come out 2008 I think it was 2008
or something like that Kyle would
probably like that what's it called
again the ruins the ruins yeah check
that [ __ ] out Khan I mean I really it's
good I really liked it the book is good
I mean the book is way better it always
is but the movie was actually I was
impressed like the movie was like
his con is not his name his name is jair
all right zair man check that [ __ ] out
man
holy parachute Doom said is that the one
with the plants yes yes that's the one
with the plants I haven't seen it I'll
check it out I feel like you would
probably like it probably would yeah
um I like it's very gruesome which I
mean the book is way more gruesome but
the movie's pretty gruesome too I just I
think they did a good adaptation of it
but it's just for some reason I was
getting the same
Vibe like when I was watching The
Descent I was like we should probably
watch The Ruins I bet Tom would really
like that one and I don't think we've
reviewed that either I've reviewed the
book maybe like on my channel do you say
we had to watch a certain yeah we have
to do yeah we have to watch a movie
tonight what it was what is it we had to
watch One Flew Over the cookies okay
yeah I've seen it many times okay we'll
watch it yeah because that's because
that's um it's classic yeah that's the
movie we're gonna do for the movie
retrospective so we're gonna watch that
tonight nurse ratchet yeah concept yeah
I saw it I figured like a lot I fear
like a lot of people have probably seen
the ruins yeah yeah Khan said yeah it's
good yeah it is okay so can't seen it
yeah yeah I have the book
you might not like it but I just have a
feeling that okay you would probably
like probably
if jair says he's good it's good yeah I
mean I I really liked it
um Danny Rowling said I'm gonna watch
that after this what's that
oh uh I guess okay which one I don't
know okay they're talking about Bleak
endings also dominant Invasion of the
Body Snatchers the 1978 ending was super
Bleak as well yeah and that's another
great Bleak ending When Donald
Sutherland is like
oh my God that's so awesome and she's
like [ __ ] [ __ ] it is it is dated but it
is effective
yeah to be honest I still think that
shit's creepy like the face that he
makes yeah like because she runs up to
him just like oh my God hey like you're
still around and you're still like a
human and he's just like yeah cool she's
like [ __ ] you know what I mean yeah
that's awesome what was weird about that
movie it's like old New York
weren't all that shit's going on it's it
is kind of creepy there wasn't newer New
York that was San Francisco it was San
Francisco I thought it was New York okay
yeah that was that was uh San Francisco
all right the the 78 one I can't
remember like what the 1956 I thought it
was New York for some reason not San
Francisco it did have a [ __ ] period
feel to it for when I was remembered I
love letters
yeah that's right he was in that I
forgot he was like that weird
psychiatrist yeah or whatever yeah
that's weird yeah I guess I gotta see it
again but yeah so um but I mean if you
haven't seen The Descent I feel like
everybody's kind of seen this set do
this is the way that you do like a
simple premise but you do it right you
know what I mean just kind of like the
thing is kind of like a simple premise
it's a bunch of dudes and they're in
like an isolated location and they get
attacked by a monster this is the same
kind of thing it's a bunch of women
they're in an isolated location they
can't get out they already have like a
bunch of [ __ ] to deal with because like
you know cavins they don't know where
they are they can't get out there's all
kind of like you know one of them breaks
a leg and all this other kind of [ __ ]
and then oh and by the way on top of
that also there are monsters that are
gonna eat them you know what I mean like
even without the monsters it still would
have been scary as [ __ ] like especially
if you're claustrophobic but then like
added that onto it and plus there's all
the kind of [ __ ] going on with yeah
particularly Juno being like an [ __ ]
and Wisconsin it's a bunch of Gringos
that are trapped or what I can't read
and I don't have my glasses hold on hold
on it says it's a bunch of Greek I was
trapped a bunch of Gringos trapped in
the rooftop on a p what on a what I
don't know
and then and then he said something else
after that uh great parent wait a minute
uh a bunch of green goes trapped on the
cave is good also yeah see I haven't
seen that one like I kind of feel like
um yeah Uncle Fester is in One Flew Over
the Cuckoo's Nest and uh yeah uh
um the remake of My Bloody Valentine was
not bad yeah I remember that being okay
I mean like the original is better but
uh Danny Rowling said nurse ratchet was
hot as [ __ ] in that film
in one flavor yeah we
always true I remember her being very
attractive yeah I was a teenager I mean
she's a villain [ __ ] but she was like
cute I was like going like that old
[ __ ] [ __ ] was [ __ ] mean and [ __ ]
but I I was like 16 when I first saw
that and I'm like I hit though
I'd love to get a hand job it's that
kind of [ __ ] you know what I mean Louise
Fletcher was also a villain in uh uh
what was that [ __ ] movie with like
the all the incest and Flowers in the
Attic yeah she was she was a villain in
that one too yeah she was in that then
she was in that too yeah she had like a
negative sexuality to her she's it was
kind of like BDSM because that [ __ ] was
cruel yeah she was cruel all right well
didn't they didn't Netflix they made a
um series called ratchet that was all
about her like obviously she wasn't in
it because she was like old by that
point but
I heard like mixed reviews like some
people really loved it and then some
people really hated it and I meant to
like get around to watching it but I
never did so I hate to like start new
series because it's like I just I don't
have a lot of time to watch stuff so as
much as I want to watch a lot of the
series it's like God damn it it's like
that's like 12 hours long and I don't
have time to watch that but I did
actually want to see that so if anybody
like would recommend it then I'm kind of
still curious to see it I know it's been
a while since it's been out but um but
yeah let's see uh Jones Perkins said I
remember watching both of these when
they came out this one and the cave uh
the cave is okay if I remember correctly
but the descent is the better movie I
kind of feel like that probably is the
case because The Descent I mean you go
on any decent horror list of like best
movies of the 21st century and the
descent is on there and honestly nobody
talks about the cave anymore I'm sure
it's not a bad movie but it's not as
memorable as this one and the thing
about Neil Marshall is that not only do
you make this but like I said in 2002
like a couple years before this he had
made dog soldiers which is also amazing
but then
I don't know I feel like he didn't want
to get Typecast as a horror director and
then he made like a couple of other kind
of movies which weren't all that well
received but I think that his kind of
career has come back now like he worked
on Game of Thrones and uh and Hannibal
like he worked on that show and stuff
like that Hannibal was a great movie no
I'm talking about the series oh the
series um so yeah so he worked on that
as well so he seems to have like bounced
back some because I feel like he made
some movies in there that weren't look
if y'all want to see a [ __ ] badass
flick Watch Hannibal Rising one of my
favorite movies I loved him we reviewed
that didn't we we were I think we maybe
we reviewed it we can check if we didn't
review we need to redo Hannibal Rising
I'm pretty sure we could move that one
and I'm pretty sure it wasn't that long
ago okay you know what I mean yeah
uh holy Parish of Doom said Leonard
Nimoy talking about uh Invasion of the
Body Snatchers is one of those uh I'm
okay you're okay author head shrinkers
yeah yeah I like I really liked his
character in that one because she don't
usually see him I don't know I know he
was in a lot of stuff but you don't
usually see him playing a character like
that he's not like a straight up Villain
at the beginning but he's like smarmy
for sure and then like he becomes Like a
Villain after like after he gets like
assimilated or whatever and I just like
really really like into that Khan said
uh Gringo is trapped on the ruins yeah
yeah that's what I mean well it's a
bunch of like yeah it's a bunch of like
American tourists and they're in Mexico
and they're like
you'll see
um yeah it's good but that one's good
too the ruins uh yeah so I guess are we
done we can call it all right so
if you haven't seen The Descent I don't
know what's the matter with you it's
like I said it's it's she doesn't know
what's the matter with you I don't know
what's the matter with you I mean if
you're into horror if you're not into
horror then you know you can get a pass
but if you're into horror I feel like
you need to see this one like I said
this is the quintessential simple
premise Done Right show don't tell very
very good like suspense building just
it's just I don't know it's just like a
really really good like really tense
movie everything you want in your horror
movies you know what I mean yeah uh
Danny rolling said Reign of Fire is a
badass movie Christian Bale versus
dragons Okay sounds from uh I think I
saw it yeah somebody loaned it to me a
long time ago I remember it being okay
but I don't really remember that much
about it but like I said I see so many
movies that it's hard for one of them to
make an impression so uh so yeah so yeah
everybody hit the like button you know
do all the regular stuff that you do and
we will be back again tomorrow evening
for our main show which I think I
mentioned it yesterday but it's gonna be
about like creepy astronaut deaths like
just anything having to do with like
astronauts and creepiness hey somebody's
like floating at like some major Tom
kind of [ __ ] like anything that's like
that or did you have to do you have the
[ __ ] radio one with the people
burning it up saying it's hot it's hot
yeah that's gonna be one of the things I
haven't decided like what all because
I'm kind of like curated like all the
stories that I don't know if that
actually happened but we'll talk about
it may have not have happened but we'll
see we'll get into it like I said I
still gotta like tomorrow I gotta like
winnow through all the notes and see
like right what we're gonna like uh put
on the show so yeah so hopefully
everybody can drop by for that tomorrow
night at 6 p.m Eastern Standard Time
thank you for dropping by and hanging
out with us today talking about The
Descent and we will see you guys again
tomorrow good night